welcome to the press conference of the
President of the European Council and of
the President of the European Commission
following the 22nd year China summit
point out that we have issued a press
release on behalf of the two presidents
and there will be a Q&A session but
first I give the floor to the President
of the European Council thank you good
afternoon everyone I am pleased that we
could speed by video conference to
discuss important topics for both the EU
and China today in fact our diplomatic
relations are 45 years old this year and
evolving our decisions today were open
and substantive and we discussed many
topics
Tirpitz we agree on but of course we
discussed also topics we disagree on we
focused on four important areas the
first one covet 19 and the economic
consequences
the economic recovery the seventh one is
the EU China relationship the third one
is Hong Kong and the important question
for us of human rights and the fourth
topic is related to the international
issues Tata Nano Camilla speed the
Kovach business is a transit or a role
location discriminate importance ponnu
the tearily transit or to transfer of
the direction Internacional Sujit the
wrong serum potassium the hotly Attell
polymer mobilizes that is not a crystal
lattice on the vector y ponnu drafted
avianna access to the moon adelmo
am a board AB in consider hunker in
hollow so obvious so - more importance
or pro economic on occasion ditch PT you
see the processor core para la cabeza
para el fondo whole ocean of sweetened
Metron plasticity
activity economic we had also the
occasion to distress
EU China relationship and we stressed
the need to implement the commitments
made at the 2019 EU China summit more
particularly we discussed very concrete
topics the first one is trade we have a
dynamic trading relationship with China
we treat an average over 1 billion euros
a day it's huge and the EU is China's
first trading partner but progress is
needed in many areas to rebalance this
relationship and we made clear that we
need to resolve concrete problems such
as market access subsidies with the
lateral issues public procurement force
technology transfers 11 Plainfield and
WTO reforms 7c location des primo de
partido de los weather continue e
anodization
an translation director relative or
service is no revenue see prosthetic or
a rebel positions across horizontally on
geography Poliquin zombunny spa Cluedo
don't delay hakushi
distrito Devonian co-locations at a time
a simple survey Dimetrodon important say
no solutions remotely Matilda mobile SEO
Internacional Genesis a solution a
porphyrin software on priests have a
yella stability Paterson automatic
Mona's Palma Nettie vollar moon a
partner proceeding Oceania allocation
economic electrician commercial for OC
travel a positive Chile the congruence
deal while a position at a national oh
yeah Alexa zombies compliment you can
listen at home is no problem start
altering the Romani I founded not here
the British on average the milk on new
consider
tenido el chico cetera and a doll is
altered at a national is also
multilateral porphyrin sake mobilization
presentation solar protection an earlier
iris or more thematic on all syrians you
on the district
in the digital eternal pasta sauce
wretched wallah the durante la
conférence the on teleconference sin he
prolonged well we told the monopolist
evil security law a little converted
little the design for my sake mean Lacan
fleet an alimony effector total more
under sponsor of a third the third point
Hong Kong and Human Rights which pressed
grave concerns about the proposed
national security law for Hong Kong we
told on China to follow the promises
made to the people of Hong Kong and the
international community regarding Hong
Kong's high degree of autonomy and
guaranteed freedoms related new suit
molecule moral principle RP do system
renew not on a certain person is a very
small rope or shin transparent earned
not interior minister on trapeze
repentant active I will turn in
considering trauma hospital a neutrally
temperate it doesn't happen except tanta
le président is overfed Palmetto Angela
neutrality policy doesn't appear open
assault on all current revenues agency
personnel no discontinuity devotee
Sunday duodenum emotional expressive mo
d cha CA la venta de sitio Canadian
dollar per watt initial literal is non
volatile no consolidations no somewhat
arbitrary alpha royal occasion
devoted edition Internacional hacia la
cuestión de l'homme Porto Cervo
in soldier neutrons virtual reality
stone left an instant like Eastern
Lupino silicon level ugly automobile is
on the ship of average the solution
Pacific
those are geometry lateral allows you to
zoom the Metro on the LAN port of the
security
the Transpo Maritim levitra the non
posso de transporte national transit
parvathi team elect astronomers the
medicine meridian l it indefinitely L
not important the pantry strategy for a
security we transfer it on eternity
don't we develop more economic will he
complete the whole the videoconference
totalitarian remedies - or a toss up or
funded through loss or decision here so
this regional rottenness finally
multilateral mercy Dhanteras humility
he'll tip the videoconference
Lucas room the pas moi LaVon Oaxaca pain
you can cry all the democracy later dude
wah lowest-paid it was women the
potentially difference the mineral team
the humanist with the other sortable she
want to die right from wrong you see you
notice you don't really pass between
sweet improve our policy on a commercial
or materi tournament silica zoom the
metal on evidence on contract
Parvati demo nature in action global
entrepreneur return in strategic
the neural period nor extreme emotional
annual aa new consider juntos 800
relation rotate respondus you were
transparent so logistically to sell
myself yet identity spiro spero
the veneer a Julia Saudi Arab Perdita
you knew saturated Fallujah
equality Western Oregon de novo equality
location the Portugal Saudi alert the
ferry port at Davos small differences in
Odisha ETA VT the who venir show
decision concrete so this is a digital
pedometer lip CGI preview model set all
the possible DiNozzo a defense volusia
menu garden rasoi
digitally conditional permit on the
tourney also met Eva Soler a little
addition was of a loss on the rancid
chef DITA Ljubljana more volatile to the
limo to verse with a partnership set up
cleanly Thank You mr. president
Madam President thank you indeed
relationship between
in the european union and china is
simultaneously one of the most
strategically important and one of the
most challenging that we have today
summit has been a much-needed
opportunity to discuss and move forward
on all aspects of this complex and vital
partnership our discussions were both
intense and they were indeed wide
ranging from trade and investment to
climate action and the digital field
from Hong Kong to human rights and of
course the coronavirus response and we
are able to take us discuss all these
issues with China but I must say mostly
important wasn't is that we must make
progress for this the summit was only a
starting point progress implies
cooperation on both sides implies
reciprocity and implies trust these have
been central pillars of our discussions
today and shall has already focused on
many of the important issues that we
discussed including on Hong Kong and
human rights and I do not want to repeat
what has been already said but let me
reiterate that for the European Union
human rights and fundamental freedoms
are non negotiated we always raise our
concerns so was it today too and insist
on having our view on these topics of
course we discussed trade and investment
and indeed the European Union is China's
biggest trading partner and China our
second biggest we will soon be in a
position to sign our agreement on
geographical indications this current is
a high level of protection for our
respective producers and that is good
and yet we continue to have an
balanced trade and investment
relationship we have not made the
progress we aim for in the last year's
summit statement in addressing market
access barriers we need to follow up on
these commitments urgently and we also
need to have more ambition on the
Chinese side in order to conclude
negotiations on an investment agreement
these two actions would address the
asymmetry in our respective market
access and improve the level playing
field between us in order to conclude
the investment agreement we would need
in particular substantial commitments
from China on the behavior of
state-owned enterprises transparency and
subsidies and transparency on the topic
of forced technology transfers and we
have raised these issues at the same
time with Premier Li and President Xi
that we expect that China will show the
necessary level of ambition to conclude
these negotiations by the end of this
year I think it is important that we
have now a political high-level approach
on these topics I've also made clear
that China needs to engage seriously on
a reform of the World Trade Organization
in particular on future negotiations on
industrial subsidies this is the
relevant framework where we have to work
together on the topic it it's a
difficult topic but this is the
framework which we have to establish to
have common binding rules we agree on
and we must continue to work on tackling
Chinese overcapacity
for example in the steel and metal
sectors and in high-technology here for
us is important that China comes back to
the international negotiation table that
we sit down there and find solution we
also pointed out the importance of
digital transformation and it's highly
assertive approach to the security the
resilience
instability of digital networks systems
and value chains we have seen
cyberattacks and hospitals and dedicated
computing centers likewise we've seen a
rise on Amla in my online it is
information and we pointed out clearly
that this cannot be tolerated we've also
discussed climate action and climate
change remains the global challenge of
our generation
China has repeatedly projected itself as
a leader on global climate issues and
China is indeed on our side on this
however being a leader brings
responsibility to follow up with actions
we urge China to commit to climate
neutrality as soon as possible after
2050 and we count on China to live up to
its commitments under the Paris
agreement and step them up and lead by
example we look forward to seeing
decarbonisation play a big role in
China's upcoming next five-year plan as
the European European Green Deal plays a
big role in our strategic agenda as well
and last but not least the corona virus
pandemic when the virus hit China the
European Union responded swiftly we
coordinated and co-financed the delivery
of over 56 tons of emergency medical
supplies China then reciprocated when
Europe faced the pandemic and we agreed
on the need to continue this mutual
solidarity we read also in supporting
countries and populations that are more
vulnerable than our own for example in
the context of the global response
initiatives well had to conclude today
has been a very intense a very frank and
a very open meeting we would want and
expect nothing less this was good it is
not possible to shape the world of
tomorrow without a
from EU China relationship however it is
time to accelerate on the very crucial
areas of our relationship to deliver on
the important commitments from last
summit and address our concerns on
reciprocity and the level playing field
as European Union we're committed to
making Swift and substantial progress we
count on the Chinese leadership to match
our level of ambition thank you madam
president we have a couple of questions
could I please ask you to turn on your
cameras and raise the blue hand as you
know by now and the first question we're
getting is from Lawrence Norman please
Lawrence could you say to whom you want
to speak with the President on the trade
and economic site and you've made clear
what you press the Chinese on and the
and the if they have not delivered on
what was their response
were there any fresh promises today that
the liver are what they promised last
year on the trade and investment side
and what newspaper band would be the
consequence if he's not resolved by the
end of the year including me in this is
around the investment agreement thank
you
so um this trade issue indeed we were
very intensive in all the meetings today
on this issue and indeed our
interlocutors responded that they
explained their view on the topics beat
the level playing field or being
subsidies or being market access and for
us was important that it is completely
okay to exchange different views and to
have different standpoints but we expect
now to step up and to lift the
negotiations that so far have been on a
very low level to a higher political
level that we really see the dedication
to have at the very end an investment
agreement so for us is important that we
step up the level of attention these
negotiations get before the end of the
summer because then this would give us a
real chance to have an investment
agreement till the end of the year if
this is not possible it would be a pity
but this all also would be difficult
then to develop our agenda 2025 together
because we have intentions to work
together they are the words put on paper
but we also need the deeds and we also
need to see that there is really
improvement on the topics where we have
different opinions I would like to add
that we need more potent leadership in
order to to explain clearly why it's so
essential for the European Union to take
more into consideration dispersion of
the level playing field for example or
another complete example the subsidies
and for example we made clear that it
was essential for us to to make more
transparency about discretion because
fair competition is clearly needed and I
hope that because of this decision today
it will be possible in national in the
next month to make more concrete
progress it would be difficult we are
not now we are aware about the huge
difficulties but it's essential for our
businesses
to be to be able to have a access to the
Chinese market if we open the open
market is also important the same time
to have more reciprocity Thank You mr.
president
next question for Stuart Lao from the
South China Morning Post thank you this
is imposed in Hong Kong I have a couple
of questions for president on the line
if I make my first question more general
one just got off the phone with the
leader that some would regard as the
world's most powerful man but others
describe him as an autocrat or even a
dictator the fee strike you as somebody
with from the EU can build a strategic
partnership in the future and my second
question is more focused on Hong Kong
are you satisfied with the response you
got from the Chinese leadership today
and if not what actions is that you
prepared to take when the national
security law is enforced thank you so we
were very clear in our conversations
that Beijing's imposition of a national
security law on Hong Kong does not
conform with the Hong Kong Basic Law nor
with China's international commitments
this was very clear the national
security law risk seriously undermining
the one country two systems' principle
and Hong Kong's high degree of autonomy
we wish to see stay in place and it is
this autonomy that has allowed hong kong
to flourish and to be so successful so
we also conveyed that china risk is very
negative consequences if it goes forward
with imposing this law the European
Union is in touch with our g7 partners
on this topic and we've made our
position very clear to the Chinese
leadership today and urged them to
reconsider of course they have a
different standpoint than us but this is
our very clear standard we conveyed to
the Chinese leadership
it's our intention to continue to
monitor the situation it pres clearly
our opinion on that and I would like to
remember that the day after the
announcement by the Chinese authorities
of the security law we reacted as
European Union immediately we reacted
and we spoke loud and clear today and we
will follow the situation thank you
we'll take a last question by Gavin Lee
from the BBC News Gavin can you hear us
please unmute we can't hear you
second is that better three years ago
president tusk talks about full external
threats you and the action from Russia
[Music]
what's the call group three years on and
so could you could you rephrase your
send would you rephrase your question
because the connection is really bad yes
I'll try and be be breathe can you give
me a sense of what your estimate is of
China as an external threat to the EU
given your comments by President HUS
three years ago if that makes sense to
the first question and the second issue
is on the comments from you talks that
you said a moment ago that some
companies misinformation and propaganda
we pointed out clearly if now that this
cannot be tolerated can you explain what
the conversation was and what the
Chinese President said in in the fight
we we have a very clear approach we
think that it's essential to have a
dialogue because we need a Dalek if we
want to promote our values if we want to
defend our interests it doesn't mean it
doesn't mean that we agree on everything
is that the case we express that on this
one point we think that we need to work
together to improve some concrete
preparation but at the same time we
disagree on very important and essential
topics and we had your children to
promote our values to explain why we
consider that it's so important to
promote and to support the human worth
to protect the minorities or to
transistor for example that the state
uses unkind is very important and
definite to respect this high degree of
autonomy in our current we had this
occasion and it's our intention at the
international level to continue to speak
also with countries with which we don't
agree about everything so indeed you
mentioned Donald Tusk and may I quote or
cite the description that the Commission
has on our new China relations you know
that we describe these relations as
being that China is for the European
Union a negotiating partner an economic
competitor and a systemic rival and you
have to see all three together and the
negotiating partner for example you can
see on that we are close to have the
agreement now on the geographical
indications this would be a negotiation
success in a certain field the economic
competitor the first question in this
press conference related to that too so
the fact that we are working hard on
having a fair market access to these
economic competitors of fair conditions
for us is not important to have the
market access to have the same outcome
but what we want is the same and fair
opportunities this is for us important
to be here clear with our economic
competitor the same goes for the topic
of the subsidies we've been discussing
for us is important that we negotiate
rules for subsidies there are subsidies
out there of course globally but that we
negotiate modern rules in the WTO
framework we can agree on and
everybody's playing by the same rules so
here economic competitor and systemic
rival that means these are two very
different systems very different views
on values what the European Union is
concerned or China and in this category
of course goes the topic of
cybersecurity we know that we've seen
attacks on cybersecurity on other cyber
attacks in the past as I said on
computing systems on hospitals and we
know the origin of the cyberattacks the
same goes for disinformation you know
that the European Union is very active
on dismantling the disinformation so by
doing so you go to the source and you
have an idea where the disinformation
comes from so on our side we put against
them the facts and the figures that are
necessary to know and this three
descriptions negotiation partner
economic competitor and systemic rival
shows the the relationship that is not
an easy one but one we're working on
Thank You Madame and mr. president this
concludes our press conference please
check our joint press release on our
both websites thank you
[Music]
you